that's not like donald trump hijack all
your time here
when it's really about your book which i
have here
i i wrote you after i read it i loved it
how did it happen
how did nine years of conversation
friendship turn into three years of
insane work and and something so
what i think is beautiful and i can say
that because i'm only responsible for
half of it
wow and it really you know it's it's
just an incredible gift
i don't know what else it's like i'm
almost embarrassed about it
well let me let me tell people best
sellers list i was just
shocked in the best possible way and and
but
at this point people are going to go
like jesus i mean what is this dude
i mean let me tell them what the thesis
is about let me tell them what the book
is
entanglement what the let me describe a
little for people who might want to
get this you're [ __ ] up your own plug
jim
um i don't care i know you don't i can't
fit in this format man
there's the jim carrey some people are
just too big for it
just me and elvis can't do it we can't
do it uh
hey man you gonna can you move back a
bit
it's the pictures that got little to
karate you got to see my karate move man
it's sorry so but what what i
immediately was grabbed by
was the fact that it's a book where jim
carrey is a character
much the way in a sitcom you know that
became
the the template now larry david started
it with curb your enthusiasm or maybe
jerry seinfeld really but that was larry
half larry's show too
but where you know jerry was jerry
seinfeld
larry is larry david so is it is it
really that's
and like is it that person or is it not
and of course the answer is both it is
and it isn't and that's what you do in a
novel you are jim carrey
right but i am a character named jim
carrey your character represents
uh me making fun of my own ego my own
you know very much reality and my own
everything
and my hunger for for specialness
and at the same time it also makes fun
of the perceptions people have about
hollywood that you know that this is
what fame is like
well you know fame is a very bizarre
thing you can't understand unless you
get it
you know you you can you can want to
walk on the moon all you want when
you're a little kid but then when you
walk
when you go there you gotta have a suit
and you gotta have air pump in or
anything like that it's no place to live
and also that's what elon musk is trying
to prove
it struck me that this is a book find
other places that are no place to live
well yeah i mean i love him but i'm
against going to mars to me it's like
vegas
you're going to mars like vegas man
they're going to shut you in a room and
control the climate i can't tell you
already i'm out it's like vegas these
days but
uh jim once again let me plug your book
let me take one more one more step
because it strikes me as a book that
could only have been written
by a canadian because you know you
canadians you know
you look at america and it's like you
want to be part of it and you don't you
know
you want to be at the party but you're
very ambivalent about it and you you
know you're a fountain of talent all the
people have come out of canada no i want
to be
i'm in the party i'm at the party i'm
you know
i'm watching the door i'm i'm making
sure there's an exit for everybody i'm
trying everything i can to let people
know
that it's not normal to sit and
watch a president of the united states
obsessively spew out purulent discharges
on twitter all day long you know
you have a question here you're back to
trump you're here you're able to believe
or not if he loses but you're obsessed
i asked you a question about your book
and we're talking about trump and the
trump really isn't a big part of the
book
no no okay no but tyranny is but tyranny
is yes well
that's a great other side of celebrity
it's a great great theme and also you
have a lot of
other celebrities by their real names
who you put words in their mouth i'm
sure some of them are mad at you
and i just have to read no i have no
idea but but i i can tell you this
so far i've uh you know nick cage loves
it he's out of his mind over it he
thought it was awesome he's like go
forward
you know uh immediately he was honored
by the whole process um
joan dangerfield sent me lovely emails
about what she loved it and how much
rodney dangerfield would have loved it
and uh and how i dealt with that that
character and kind of the
the fear of the future loss of ai and
all that stuff
and then we're actually going to be
talking to dead people and stuff soon
having relationships with them i i just
want to read one little quote here
because i thought it was so funny
pointing to the fact that it's so hard
nowadays to actually
do parody you cannot stay ahead of how
weird [ __ ] is and at the end i don't
want to give too much away but during
the alien invasion
kanye west says you need not be afraid
they speak to me in supernatural verses
i am one with their jam
and i'm not so sure he didn't say that
this week
yeah i know it's a very strange thing
where parody becomes very parallel with
uh with reality
but uh we gotta mark these things you
know he's one of the great characters of
our zeitgeist at this moment
and uh i wanted him to have a place in
it you know no matter what he's doing i
can't figure it out
for me it was a real gift in this time i
was i
was home you know we had a month off the
last month and to have this book
really gave me a few days of i read it
very fast
great pleasure i recommend it so great
man love to see you
hear that from you i i admire you so
much and and your opinions i'll finish
your thought
i love that and all right you're just
very very lucky
yeah yeah we both are all right let's
hope we have luck
in person soon and i will see you soon
jim carrey absolutely
all right great to see you bill thank
you